look they're not all gonna be winners
let's just be upfront about this okay
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so I need to do the flip side
of the coin because a few days ago I did
my most anticipated films of 2020 well I
got to do the flip side which is the
movies that I am pretty dang sure are
gonna suck now I I try to not take cheap
shots with this there are some movies
that are just some they're plenty there
will be plenty of movies released this
year that are just not for me not
targeted at me not meant to please me
meant for an audience that I don't get
in there very much not for me I try hard
not to put movies like that on this list
because that's just taking cheap shots I
try and restrict it to things that even
if it's maybe not something that it's
totally in my wheelhouse I suspect is
also going to let down even the people
who are the target audience for this
thing so I've got seven of these cuz I'm
not gonna Pat it out to ten if I
couldn't find ten that I was pretty
certain about and possibly point out
this is not me saying that I want these
to be bad or I want these to be do I
want them to fail I honestly don't
really want any movie to fail especially
if I ever end up saying these it'd be
really nice to be proven wrong because I
mean that's happened sometimes and it's
wonderful I don't expect it to happen
with these though and these are not in
any order of like one I'm least certain
will be suck that will suck to the one
I'm most certain that will suck now I'm
doing these in order of release date
across the year so it's just
chronological so kicking things off
Doolittle
so first warning sign is being dumped in
Jan you
barri it has a troubled production
history it went badly over-budget it
supposedly had some notable reshoots
which I suppose makes it a very true
successor to the original Doctor
Dolittle no not the one with Eddie
Murphy the one before that which also
ran over a budget and a lot of
production problems I don't know what it
is why they keep making these big-budget
movies with lots of animals cuz same
thing happened to friggin Evan Almighty
like there's a pattern at this point
with these things but the fact that it's
being dumped in January that is a big
sign I think that everybody involved can
smell the bomb on this thing and they
just want to get it out quietly be done
with it and move on as quickly as
possible the trailer didn't look awful
but it also didn't look great and all
the other warning signs just made me oh
no this is gonna be bad after that I
hate to get a phantom mother down but
look I'm sorry Sonic the Hedgehog
because while redesigning and fixing the
look of Sonic was no bad thing it was a
good call that was far from the only
thing wrong with that trailer the field
the story that it was setting up and was
gonna tell the humor this thing a major
fundamental problems and re skinning the
the pointy blue brat is not gonna fix
structural character bad humor etc
problems those will exist regardless so
while it may look far less nightmarish
then that early trailer made it appear I
don't think there's gonna be good folks
after that we have bloodshot
which is a movie I actually kept
forgetting was getting adapted till I
saw the trailer and the trailer was a
bad but it's not a good sign that the I
and I went back and forth on this
because the trailer gives away what
feels like there's no way it isn't a
late-game plot twist like the sort of
second act tongue but the thing is I
don't think there was anything to sell
it on other than the twist because aside
from the twist aside from the gimmick it
looks just generic as hell
it looks so middle-of-the-road for
action movies for superhero movies for
Vin Diesel it just looks so bland and I
suppose they had to spoil the gimmick
because that's in theory the only thing
going for it I mean to be fair that is
also what it looked like in the trailers
leading up to edge of tomorrow but I'm
not gonna say that that gives me any
reason to hope for this thing after that
yeah the woman in the window
you may or may not have heard of this
one this is an Amy Adams lead thriller
sort of thing Fox I believe was Fox
produced it Disney got a hold of it and
had massive reshoots done when it's when
it tested horribly specifically because
of the third act third act ie the ending
so a couple of things this thing got
delayed by months significant reshoots
all to the ending now even if they make
the ending quote-unquote better here's
the thing about anything with a mystery
element like thrillers tend to have even
if you change the ending the first two
thirds were laying hints and groundwork
and false leads and red herrings
designed for
the ending you're no longer using so
even if on paper whatever new ending
they put in there is better than what it
was before the first two thirds of the
film aren't gonna build to the ending
they have anymore
it's so still gonna be a mess even
though even the people who did the music
have walked away from this that oh man
this this thing this has a strong smell
of just complete Turkey
about it after that what have we got Oh
huh
talking about just swimming in a sea of
mediocrity the hit man's wife's
bodyguard
yeah the hit man's bodyguard did well
enough to warrant a sequel and it's not
like the hit man's bodyguard was an
awful movie but it was such a
middle-of-the-road just filling the
space nobody's bringing their a-game
kind of movie and for that to get a
sequel a sequel that I have no doubt
nobody involves is passionate about and
there's only getting made because the
first one made a decent profit yeah not
a lot of hope that brings us to Monster
Hunter which you may or may not realize
was getting a movie this is a
long-running video game franchise and
it's being adapted by Paul WS Anderson
and from what I could see it is being
loosely adapted by Paul WS Anderson and
the thing about Paul loosely adapted
Paul WS Anderson and video games that
should ring a bell if you are at all
familiar with the Resident Evil series
of films here's the thing those kind of
had their charm in a way they were nuts
and not good but they kind of a kind of
word the standard bearer of the certain
kind of over-the-top stupid kind of fun
thing but they were also very much a
act of an earlier decade it was weird
that that franchise continued for as
long as it did when it felt so early
2000s and Paul WS Anderson kind of as a
director is stuck in that era so the
idea that they handed him another video
game franchise oh boy
that the this is the this is the
foundation that train wrecks get build
out of and last one the conjuring the
devil made me do it
aka the conjuring three now this is a
very up and down franchise because it
and it's fairly wide spanning at this
point because there's the conjuring and
the conjuring to dub but there's also
Annabelle
there's Annabelle the creation which was
surprisingly good there was another
Annabelle one that I forget the name of
there was a movie called La Llorona
which was connected to it there was the
nun which you know this thing's very up
and down but the core of it the actual
conjuring movies as opposed to the
spin-offs have always been very solid so
why do I have this on a list of movies
that are gonna suck because the secret
ingredient of those movies was director
James Wan the guy behind the original
saw the guy behind insidious the guy
behind Aquaman
he can take insanity and sell it this is
not being directed by him this is being
directed by the guy who directed La
Llorona which part of the same universe
and was not good so that this this for
me I expect to be the nail in the coffin
because I suspect not only will not be
good there they're gonna have to spend
more money on it cuz they they bring out
the bigger budgets for this and it's not
gonna make fun
back or if it does not nearly in the
amounts that that they want and maybe we
can probably put the conjuring universe
to bed with this one cuz I'm pretty sure
it's gonna suck so those are seven films
in twenty honey I feel confident saying
will be terrible what are your thoughts
about them whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do
buttons links like subscribe share
patreon support maybe it's a thought
there's a link in the description
plus there's links other things like
merch books social media stuff that I'm
on check it out but you also don't have
to because at the end of the day you are
at the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is a
jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]